our discussion of lisman squares
estimation so far was based on the case
where we have a single unknown random
variable and a single observation and we
are interested in a point estimate of
this single unknown random variable what
happens if we have multiple observations
or parameters for example suppose that
instead of a single observation we have
a whole vector of observations and of
course we assume that we have a model
for these observations once we observe
our data the numerical value for this
vector or what is the same numerical
values for each one of these observation
random variables then we are placed in a
conditional universe where these values
have been observed then we notice that
the arguments that we carried out did
not rely in any way on the fact that X
was one-dimensional exactly the same
argument goes through for the multi
dimensional case and simply the answer
is again that the optimal estimate the
one that minimizes the mean squared
error is again the conditional
expectation of the unknown random
variable given the values of the
observations so this gives us a simple
and much more general solution that also
applies to the case of multiple
observations now what if we have
multiple parameters once more the
argument is exactly the same and we
obtain that the optimal estimate of any
particular parameter is going to build a
conditional expectation of that
parameter given the observations
so if our parameter vector is something
of this form consisting of several
components then the LMS estimates of the
jth component of our parameter vector is
going to be simply the conditional
expectation of this parameter given the
data that we have obtained
and this gives us the most general
solution to the problem of list mean
squares estimation when we have multiple
parameters and multiple observations one
very simple concept that applies to all
possible cases unfortunately however our
worries are not over even though LMS
estimation has such a simple and such a
general solution things are not always
easy let us see what's happening no
matter what we have to first find out
the posterior distribution of theta
given the observations that we have
obtained and this is done using the
Bayes rule which we have written here
and this is how you evaluate the
denominator in Bayes rule
what are the difficulties that we may
encounter one first difficulty is that
in many applications we do not
necessarily have a good model or were
not very confident about our model of
the observations if X and theta are
multi-dimensional such a model might be
difficult to construct setting this
issue aside there is a further issue the
conditional expectation of theta given X
may be a complicated nonlinear function
of the observations this means that it
may be difficult to analyze but even
more important it may be very difficult
to calculate even after you have
obtained your data let us understand why
this might be the case suppose that
theta is a multi-dimensional parameter
then in order to calculate the
denominator that's involved here in the
Bayes rule when you integrate with
respect to theta you have to actually
carry a multiple a multi-dimensional
integral and this can be very
challenging or sometimes practically
impossible even if you had this
denominator term in your hands still in
order to calculate a conditional
expectation you would have to calculate
once more an integral of theta J
integrated against the posterior
distribution of the vector theta but
this integral should be once more over
all the parameters so it would be a
multi-dimensional integral in the
general case and that's one additional
source of difficulty and this is the
reason why we will also consider an
alternative to list min squares
estimation which is much simpler
computationally and much less demanding
in terms of the model that we need to
have in our hands